all right joining us now with reaction
my opening monologue my interview with
Carter page is the house Intel Committee
Chairman California Congressman Devin
Nunez congressman the Nunez memo has now
been totally completely corroborated by
you and people I got him shipped to me
have been proven to be one of the
biggest Liars in the country I won't
drag you into politics that that
political commentary let me get your
reaction number one it was the bulk of
information used to get a FISA warrant
Clinton's dirty dossier full of Russian
lies you just heard Carter page your
thoughts start with most people in the
media never even bothered to read our
three page memo that was designed to be
just a short compilation to protect
sources and methods because we only
wanted to get out the main points which
were what that they used the dossier the
dirt from the Clinton campaign to make
up the bulk of the FISA application
matter of fact they lead with it in the
FISA application so that's what we
really wanted to get to the American
people because we believed at that time
that most Americans would agree and I
think they they would agree if
journalism wasn't so dead as you said in
your monologue most Americans when you
talk to them when they're not watching
the other cable news network so you
talked to them about is it okay for me
as a politician to go out and and pay
someone to dig up dirt on my on my
opposing candidate whether it whether
it's running for president or governor
or something else and then feed it into
the FBI an FBI that's controlled by my
own party that only happens in Banana
Republic so that was the point of the
memo and it's sad that the media has
failed to cover it but what's even more
surprising now is now that we've been
totally vindicated with the release of
this FISA just the pieces of the FISA
applications over the weekend you
continue to see the media they're going
absolutely crazy and I've never seen
anything like it and I just I think
you're like you said journalism is dead
in this country and I don't know what to
do about it
you know what is ironic in all of this
if Hillary follows money through a law
firm
they hire an OP research firm but I have
no problem with op research that's
politics then they hire a foreign
national I thought foreign nationals
wardens supposed to impact our elections
but the dossier according to steel
himself in an interrogatory in Great
Britain he says its raw intelligence
never verified never corroborated but
everybody that signed off on that
warrant signed off on unverified
uncorroborated Russian lies that were
literally designed to really steal an
election after they rigged an
investigation into what is irrefutable
crimes incontrovertible evidence of
obstruction and a violation of the
patriarchy by Hillary where is this how
does our how does our constitutional
republic survive well it can't survive
without it it cannot survive without a
free and open press actually doing their
job right so so so let's just talk about
the obvious thing that that's out there
that you're alluding to and that is that
that the very thing that the Moller
investigation is all about is seen if
the Trump campaign colluded with the
Russians to get dirt on Hillary and use
it against her now we actually know that
that is exactly what Hillary Clinton did
Hillary Clinton paid people went through
intermediaries that got dirt from
Russians to use it against Donald Trump
yeah that's that's what happened so
let's start there but then let's go with
some of the other nonsense that you're
seeing now you actually have people out
there in the media mainstream media that
are now talking about well the regs
don't necessarily say that you have to
to verify all the evidence well look I
think that's crazy talk you absolutely
should have to verify and validate the
evidence that you're using to have
probable cause but when you go to a
secret court to spy on an American
citizen but they fed the poor Russian
lies bought and paid for by the
opposition candidate and they purposely
didn't inform the court no and would
have approved these warrants if they
knew the truth
they went out of their way not to do it
so that's another point that they've
been trying to make so they went out of
their way instead of just saying look
candidate two paid for this paid for
this dirt on candidate one candidate two
would have been Hillary Clinton that
would have been a very simple way to
describe it in the FISA application
before the judge now here's something
else that that actually my colleagues
mr. Gowdy and mr. Ratcliffe from Texas
who who did a lot of these FISA warrants
in his career and it has it has had the
opportunity to look at these in quite
detail he continually makes the point
which is a very good one it's not so
much how wrong is what they put into the
FISA applications that's that's really
bad but what's even worse is the
exculpatory evidence that they left on
the cutting-room floor so for example
but for example there's something really
important if if you had the the
information that that you have with with
with Bruce or okay who's at the heart of
this because his wife was working for
fusion GPS the Bruce or information
he knew that Christopher still didn't
like Trump and it want Trump to win the
FBI had that incentive helped put it
together that's right what you did is is
to help this Democratic Republic survive
I actually worry about this abuse of
power I worry about a corrupt media
we're not going to stop on this program
thank you for all you've done mr.
chairman thank you